[Music]
President Trump is lashing out at the
FBI after reports a special counsel of
Robert Miller fired a top FBI agent in
August from his Russia investigation
team because of anti-trump text he may
have sent the president tweeting
yesterday after years of Comey with the
phony and dishonest Clinton
investigation and more running the FBI
his reputation is in tatters worst in
history but fear not we will bring it
back to greatness
this morning the president doubled down
calling out the hypocrisy between how
the agency has treated Michael Flynn
versus Hillary Clinton well I feel badly
for general Flynn I feel very badly he's
led a very strong life and I feel very
badly John I will say this Hillary
Clinton lied many times to the FBI
nothing happened to her
Flynn lied and they destroyed his life I
think it's a shame Hillary Clinton on
the fourth of July weekend went to the
FBI not under oath it was the most
incredible thing anyone's ever seen she
lied many times nothing happened to her
Flynn lied and it's like they ruined his
life it's very unfair meanwhile a
prominent lawmaker is calling for the
Clinton email investigation to be
reopened in light of these new
developments I worked in the Justice
Department for many years
FBI agents should not bring in their own
political bias into these investigations
and the fact that this was one of the
lead agents on the Hillary Clinton email
investigation if true I think it's very
disturbing and possibly could call for
reopening of that investigation
all right so big developments every day
when you wake up Brian Wright with yeah
mornings are better with friends I mean
it's just unbelievable how much and
thank you very much for the promo I owe
you one by the way watch Kimberly
tonight what are you doing after this
Peter striker I'm amazed at what he was
a part of he was a part of the Hillary
interview okay he's part of that he is a
part of looking through the 35,000
emails they propped up on Anthony Weiner
his laptop he might have been part I may
be an advocate we're about to find out
because he would not commit to an
interview with the House Intelligence
Committee to fusion GPS and making that
part of the investigation so this guy's
a main part of it now he said human
resources which is interesting people
call him up and ask how many sick days
they have left so we go to human
resources with an investigative
background it's bizarre what has
happened and I'm wondering if he is the
only one interesting Katie nice to have
you here it's great to be here thank you
so much so what do you make of these
developments well I give Bob molar
credit for moving the guide to human
resources however he was not fired some
people keep saying he was fired she was
not but the more we learn about how the
Clinton email investigation was handled
the dirtier it looks if you look at the
web surrounding the investigation
whether it's this guy who was part of it
and was an anti-trump
Pro Hillary person sending these texts
to someone he was having an affair with
right during the investigation
you add in Andrew McCabe whose wife was
friends with the Clintons and the
McAuliffe's were close to the Clintons
then on top of it you add in Loretta
Lynch who's told Comey
to call this a matter not a criminal
investigation sure and then you go back
to Comey
and what he said when he exonerated
Hillary Clinton saying that yes we there
have evidence of potential violations
the statues but nobody's really going to
press this case and then we find out
that he wrote the exoneration of Hillary
Clinton months ahead of time the more we
learn the dirtier it is and it seems
like they need to look at it again all
right so Jessie where does this go well
not well for this guy working in the
rubber room our HR looks about as
crooked as Hillary if this guy's intact
from pretty bad he's anti Trump and he
is the lead investigator of Trump he
interviewed Flynn himself and didn't
even warn Flynn that he was coming to
interview him put him under oath Flynn
didn't even know he was under oath Flynn
didn't even have a lawyer present during
the interview so you have that then also
led the Hillary Clinton email
investigation and apparently he was the
one of the ones that changed the
language that Comey said from grossly
negligent to extremely careless and as
you know that's the statute grossly
negligent which would have triggered the
indictment
so you also have the FBI director McCabe
whose wife donated to Clinton Ally Terry
McAuliffe didn't tell us about that and
now we're learning that McCabe is the
point of contact for the Clinton funded
fake Russian dossier which we haven't
heard anything about from the FBI yet
and they're stonewalling on the
documents from the tarmac meeting with
Bill Clinton and Loretta Lynch and we
now know from the documents that we have
seen
they were frantically trying to cover it
up and the Moller team stacked with
Democratic donors Muller is commis
professional mentor and it looks like
commis now probably guilty of removing
FBI documents after he was fired and
illegally leaking them the whole thing
looks really bad and I really don't
trust the integrity of the investigation
anymore there we go all right so one do
you think this is a very problematic for
the president yeah I tell you what's
problematic
general softball coach general Flynn
pleading guilty on Friday and then I
think people here are just so desperate
to try to distract and derail what is
obvious and what's in front of us all
which is the president is in trouble in
terms of that investigation with Flint
having pleaded guilty made a deal with
Muller and potentially now going to tell
secrets that could lead up the trail
there apparently Jared Kushner in the
target I think people here and I think
the president are just desperate to try
to distract people so you go ahead this
is a totally fake news this story's fake
news because guess what what's an FBI
allows agents to express their opinions
you can have a political opinion on the
problem ya know in terms of your plan
didn't he didn't the reason he was sent
to HR jesse is that Robert only wants to
be cleaner than Caesar's wife or
whatever right and so when he learned
that this guy had in Twitter or emails
that could be uncovered expressed it's
hitting ABC to let the clinton
instigation let me just tell you
something removing them they do anything
let me just say some policemen honest
two FBI agents all have personal
opinions it doesn't mean they can't do
their job just enjoy nonpartisan
investigation yeah because he wouldn't
let me just tell you something he was
regarded by FBI agents in Washington as
the best he is a very good he totally
botched the question no that's your
opinion that's your politics but there
is no evidence that would have suggested
that Hillary Clinton being that nobody
won Hillary Clinton is the one who
thinks he botched everything he's great
recently it was great or bad I'm just
saying nobody's suggesting there was any
basis on which charge Hillary Clinton
with a crime at the shoot and during the
Clinton investigation there was an FBI
agent
texting his mistress anti-hillary
pro-trump tax messages I guarantee you
he would have you would have to put a
whole bunch of Americans in the dock if
you said tweeting something that was
anti Trump couldn't do that's not the
point the point is that based on the
exact investigation that he was he was
heavily involved in he was involved in
the Clinton investigation he's involved
in the Trump investigation with the
Special Counsel Bob Muller removed him
for a reason and for you to also say
that Comey didn't think anything was
wrong well then why did he say about
Hillary Clinton there is evidence of
potential violations of the statutes
guarding the handling of classified he
also said that nobody no prosecutor
would bring a case against an
investigation we're into a situation
where the real story today is things
like will Trump pardon his people John
Dowd his lawyer saying Oh Trump can't be
found guilty of obstruction because he's
the commander in chief he can do
anything he wants to do says trunkpeople
and people who are buying into this
story about straw are just playing into
Trump's hands no in fact over the
weekend you listen to Sunday shows even
reluctantly you saw a lot of these hosts
go well this plays exactly what the
Republicans were saying yes they have a
problem with the way in which the FBI at
the highest levels was going about this
interrogation there's one aspect that
has not been brought up yet and that is
why for the longest time
mccabe as well as this guy struck we
didn't know his name ducking the ducking
the request to have them come in front
of the House Intelligence Committee now
they finally acquiesced to Devon Nunez
and will come in and speak although
McCabe says I have a conflict with my
schedule I wish Mike Flynn had a
conflict with his schedule when he was
told by Strock that he had to go under
under oath and answer that question I
think there are many more people than
struck who would say that general Flynn
had to go under oath because remember
Sally eighths at the Justice Department
who was the acting like Attorney General
at the time everybody said this guy has
told lies about his meeting Clinton
Russia that's a whole different kettle
efficient you guys are just trying to
throw everything in and then you know
what you want to whip up on Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton's not the issue
here the issue here is Trump potential
position between the two methods Hillary
Clinton repeatedly didn't tell the truth
she destroyed her emails after they were
subpoenaed she smashed blackberries with
hammers she waited for the FBI interview
she never was put under oath general
Ford never put now she's here with
nobody at risk yet he was put under oath
without a lawyer and he's now lost
everything she was never she was nobody
there's no evidence that she was like
you say that again because she bleached
bitter email oh yeah yeah okay nobody
says that she was hacked or the farm any
foreign government gained information
nobody just because there's a double
standard does not mean that Michael
Flynn's lying to the FBI which even
president Trump admits he did it doesn't
justify that however there is a double
standard and in America people have
serious questions about our federal
institutions the FBI being one of them
and when you had this long list of
conflicts of interests people do
question why Hillary Clinton got a pass
when a number of other people who did
far less than her did not well what went
on list of interest exists and
mine because he has a personal opinion I
caught the idea that the the deputy FBI
director at the Times wife was was
friends with the Clintons what he had a
campaign contribution and ran it wasn't
covered no it wasn't an today his wife
and believe again why can't my wife run
for often they say oh because she's
running you can't do your job
parents of impropriety
I'm amazed that you guys who are
normally so pro law enforcement would
agree when the president attacks the FBI
as in powder and then the worst and I
wish he would have been more specific
and said the operation told me
comfortable with that at all because
some of the hardest-working Isles the
inference was there that it wasn't to
disparage the FBI and the rank and file
and the hard-working men and women
terminated right and mates that he's hot
I know we all know what he's talking
about
I don't know you don't think he's FBI is
the worst in history should have said
banishment
I just think you guys are falling for
Trump's tactics here and trying to
distract people from the Flint
investigation and from the worst taxes
over my quads like me because that's all
he does he distracts people he plays
these games but when you guys know what
a distraction would be a distraction
would be bringing up something at Gitmo
that would be a distress like sending
missiles over into Milosevic backyard
under investigation
bin Laden but but here's the thing this
is this is there's nobody else paying
attention this is played out almost as
if it was a movie just when people
wonder about where James Comey and
company were doing and what they were up
to
if they were actually playing this on
the straight and narrow out comes this
revelation from Muller about Strock
having these anti-trump tweets that come
forward and they've moved him out into
resources and he's at the Nexus of
everything controversial I would think
you would praise a man is exactly what
you saw this happened in August yeah
threatens ensure in order to disclose
it's a kind of House Intelligence
Committee here a business right away
they said there's a potential hit you I
have an opinion that we're not going to
risk it you're gone he's gone I should
be plotting why you're gone